the first a new first-ever aew TNT
champion fresh off of the TNT tournament
championship pay-per-view double or
nothing back here on the Rich Eisen show
the very popular Cody Rhodes how are you
Ben Cody I'm doing just fine and dandy
where are you calling it from are you
calling in from the state of Florida
right now Cody yep I mean I'm in
Jacksonville at Daly's place right by
the the stadium's worked out on the Jags
wonderful Flex field yeah cuz you're all
over that field Cody I mean know what
walk me through what you guys have been
doing during the pandemic and how you've
been able to put television shows
together and obviously have an
incredible competition over the weekend
well it's this has been such an honor
and a challenge to do with a large scale
production in terms of our largest asset
as a wrestler especially as a good guy
wrestler is the crowd so now we have
nope we have no crowds and we can't get
crowds during this pandemic obviously
and every room you walk into you've got
to be tested and temperature scanned but
all of that aside we were able to put on
this really just some kind of magical
pay-per-view where I think most of our
wrestlers and I was pretty proud of the
roster they tuned into the box that is
the hard cam and the thing of four cams
and they really addressed the viewer
sitting at home the father-son family
because we don't have our instant
feedback the pops the boos the cheers of
a live crowd this pay-per-view this past
week weekend
the sequel double or nothing show was
just gangbusters every match very
diverse buffet of styles having Iron
Mike Tyson their two beers in the TNT
title it was just lovely yeah Cody I
mean getting Iron Mike to kind of give
you a little bit of an assist and then
officially award you the belt how'd you
get dad you get Mike and
and all this Mike had come to the first
double or nothing which was at the MGM
Grand a year ago right and he was it was
a fan of just pro wrestling in the
industry and he had wanted to do
something and this seemed like a really
great thing for him to do as he went
above and beyond his obligation was to
bring the TNT championship and presented
to the winner at the brand-new Belk and
he also you know in true Mike fashion
and then true shenanigan pro wrestling
fashioned chased off jake the snake'
roberts and that was a beautiful moment
i also shared a I haven't told anyone
this but I shared a nice moment with
Mike behind the scenes where he used a
little my baby oil to put on his chest
in his arms and I helped him rub it in
it was actually a pretty surreal pretty
surreal but I wanted him to look as
jacked as possible that guy looks great
by the way
absolutely great just so fun to have him
all right Cody I have some follow-up
questions okay so um did he ask for the
baby oil or did you offer him said baby
although so he asked for the baby oil
because he just you know he so I think
he saw the other wrestlers or typically
putting on a little baby oil or water
you know wrestling tradition yes and I I
mean I made sure he had it but before we
went out he just kind of sprayed it it
was a little spray bottle of it he just
sprayed it on his chest in his arm but I
thought you can't have her you can't ya
know you gotta you got to give it to
classic Nature Boy Buddy Rogers before
even Nature Boy Ric Flair where you rub
that stuff in and I was able to assist
in that moment a real bond over that
moment I mean I was doing the same thing
so I back and of course the fact that he
handed me the title where were big big
walkaway moments for me over the weekend
and in terms of Tyson you say you know
as we saw he looks very much in shape
that he can give us some rounds is it
true he's he might get back into
fighting but you know the bare knuckles
and what's going on with him he's 53
Cody what am i it looks like Mike is
gonna fight I know he's close personal
friends with with Tony Khan and Tony has
offered him the run of the mill in terms
of I saw him pushing the big dumbbells
in the in the weight room at the stadium
I saw him training with Vitor Belfort on
strike so even when he was here for
something fun and character-driven he
was training for something and I believe
they're they're pretty close to maybe
announcing a deal I could be wrong but I
people want to see Iron Mike they want
to see an Iron Mike knockout they want
to see him knock somebody out so I I
mean 53 but in great shape I think it's
a unique story I think we all kind of
want to see it right well Cody I got to
be honest with you I had Mike on this
show a few years ago and that was back
when right in the middle of the hour
with the radio clock not to get too deep
in the woods about the actual hosting of
this program but our radio clock we were
required to take a 60-second break right
at the bottom of the hour and usually we
would have a guest of like mic on before
that break and then we'd sit there for
60 seconds and then we'd continue the
conversation I asked him right before
the break hey do you ever think about
going back how many rounds can you give
me right now and his response was I
don't like to think that way because it
sends me to a very dark place then he
looked at me
I took the break on the spot Cody and
the 60 seconds felt like 60 minutes I'm
not gonna lie to you so I don't know I
don't know I don't know how Mike would
fare in that ring or who would fare with
Mike in that spot to be very honest with
anything that's a cold 60 seconds at
sound advice I held onto that break I
held on to that break like a rock in the
ocean Cody I was I was
on for dear life sir I mean that guy is
I mean he's been there and he has done
that that's for sure
I'll tell you the muscle memories there
the fast fast hand I know that Twitter
and social they've seen it he's he's got
a knockout left in him I don't know
about how many rounds but definitely a
knockout I bet so man hey I remember
when you came in studio here you've been
here before with your lovely wife Brandi
and this the aw was just getting started
and I remember you were caught in a lot
of politics involved with wrestling and
and and and the forces of the business
and the politics of the business kind of
working against you in a way and this
thing has been a home run to use that
phrase and I know it's different from
the sports that the cons are normally
associated with but is this exactly what
you would dreamed of or thought about
when you started this thing it's been
genuinely but bigger than I anticipated
I knew the audience was there for it and
a hunger was there but the production
and the scope of it and the success of
it on Wednesday nights would dynamite
and and how it's doing opposed by WWE
that's such a beautiful competition
showcasing how many wrestling fans there
are I think since the last time we spoke
I've really stepped outside of the
political aspects of it and and really
just leaned into the things that I can
control this specific talent that I
manage solely and help work with them on
their interviews and theirs their
segments and then my own personal stuff
Toni especially in this pandemic era of
wrestling toni has proven to be such a
significant least smart wrestling owner
and matchmaker I mean a true just
matchmaker helping we've had to do a lot
of taped content so the patchwork he put
together throughout the pandemic was
amazing it made my job a lot easier
okay and I mean look if if we held a
pay-per-view event Chris gear right and
I was fighting if you will this is just
throw me out okay
I'm looking at my guy Chris I'm already
worried for you I would have to win it
right yes I mean the executive vice
president of all elite wrestling won
this past week we're speaking to him
right now right right boss right boss
yet yes is that it is that in the fine
print I mean I know you know I'm you
might have a non-disclosure but I don't
know right so I would say it this way we
would win if I was booking it and and
you coming in as a celebrity guest on it
for the pro-am style aspect we would
absolutely have to do a tag match yes
tag match maybe it's you and I against
Wardlow and mjf too you know not so
savory characters and obviously I can do
some heavy lifting here you come in you
hook the leg one two three it's all over
every network we're we're off and
rolling viral moment of course you're
coming in you know there's a little
element of favoritism but people like
you you're winning
Cody I appreciate that and plus you know
you married somebody went to the
University of Michigan so you know how
smart and now that's what we are so put
it all together once we're through the
other side of this thing I would be more
than happy to have a cameo in any way
shape or form that you would want me to
on all Elite Wrestling and I'll bring
the baby oil how does that sound that is
that's a recipe for pure pure success
that's it right there and hopefully
we're we're through these woods you know
sooner than later safely and responsibly
getting crowds back and man getting
getting you to an event okay just gotta
stand on the apron take the tag I'm sure
there's a couple moves you can pop off
being a michigan guy I'm sure we could
do that I'm two years younger than Mike
I might need a little bit more in the
weight room to get to Mike's level on
that front but it's it's possible none
of what we just said is is impossible
none of it Pro Wrestling and like you
know you already kind of called me out
on the boss ass I know
a man I always enjoy our chats best your
lovely wife and best to everybody there
keep doing what you're doing stay
healthy stay safe let's get through this
and I would love to be part of
everything that you're doing Wednesday
night's 8:00 Eastern on TMT it's it's it
has been dynamite congratulations on it
man thank you sir so so much to look
forward to chatting with you again thank
you and the match you got it that's it
oh did you enjoy that oh I loved it it's
great right I mean you what's your
handicap you play Oh are you talking
about golf bro yeah I'm talking about I
loved it I and I caught I caught wind
avoid the discussion or who you would
rather ride with yeah I'm with Tom Brady
not winning he's dead last who wouldn't
wanna ride with Tom's like my hero
I'm Tom as my legit sports hero sports
how do you not want to ride with Tom and
again you know what could beat him you
know what school he went to right Cody
you know what I do I do my wife and I'm
sure you're gonna remind me I know hey
look he's at the top of the flowchart in
terms of all-time greats to come out of
that great institution of higher
learning I'll bring it up any single
time who's currently winning the poll
right now Chris is it Brady still in
dead last
yeah Brady dead last 12 percent
remaining leads away 41 go to at Rich
Eisen show and vote Cody okay attaboy
you take care of yourself you'd be well
that's Cody Rhodes at Cody Rhodes on
Twitter at American Nightmare Cody on
Instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here